[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Please
join me in welcoming
Abdoulaye and Ibrahim.
[APPLAUSE]
ABDOULAYE BARRY: My
name is Abdoulaye.
And I would like to think
Craig for inviting us,
and thank you all for coming.
And thanks to our guests
who came here to support us,
from New York, from Guinea,
and from Portland, Oregon.
This is my brother Ibrahim, and
we live in Portland, Oregon.
So we're here to talk about
ADLaM, a story that begin
almost more than 25 years ago.
And we'll try to see what we can
say about it within the next 30
or 40 minutes.
So as you can see here, ADLaM
is the name of the alphabet,
and the Pular and
Fulfulde is the language.
Next slide.
So I just wanted to give
some background information
about Africa before we
start talking about ADLaM.
So this is the map of Africa.
It's got a diverse population,
all races and all religions.
Almost all of them.
And it's got six of the top
12 fastest growing economies
in the world.
And it's got half
a billion people
who are subscribers
to mobile services,
and a quarter billion of
those who use smartphones.
There are more than 2,100
languages in Africa,
and those are grouped
into fives groups.
As you can see here,
Afroasiatic and Saharan,
Niger-Congo, Khoisan,
and Austronesian.
And there are 54
countries in Africa.
And Fulani, which is the
language that we speak,
and for which we created
the ADLaM alphabet,
is spoken in 23 countries
of those 54 countries.
And as you can see on the map
here, you can see up there--
you see it in the red--
that's the Niger-Congo subgroup.
And Fulani is up there
between Guinea and Mali.
Fulanis.
There are more than 50
million of them in Africa.
And you can-- if we
go to the next slide--
so this is actually a map of
Western and Central Africa.
From Senegal up
here where it says
Futa Toro all the way to Sudan.
These are regions
where you can actually
find Fulanis in Africa.
In almost all of the
countries of West Africa,
the 16 countries plus some
countries of Central Africa,
and then as far as Sudan,
around the Nile River.
So you can find Fulanis.
They are called
Fulanis by the British
and they got that name
from the Hausa people.
And the French people
refer to us as Peul,
and they got those
names by the first tribe
they encountered when they
arrived in Africa, the Wolof
people.
But we call ourselves Pullo if
it's one and Fulbhe, for many.
And there are other names.
The Arab people
use [? Fellata. ?]
And Fula is also at term
used by the Mandingoes.
And there are also
some other subgroups
within the group of Fulani
people, the Wodaabhe,
the Bororo, the Wassulu people,
and the Toucouleur in Senegal.
And we are historically
nomadic people,
and that's explain why we
are spread all over Africa,
because we are cattle
herders, so we--
wherever we find green
pasture, that's where we take
our cattle, and that's
the reason why--
one of reasons, and why we
extended all over Western
and Central Africa.
And when we embraced
Islam in the beginning
of the 11th century, and then
we started spreading Islam,
and also used the
other reason that
explains why we spread
over from the Senegal delta
all the way to
Nigeria and Sudan.
So this is the Fulai language.
Like I mentioned earlier,
there are 50 million--
at least 50 million
Fulanis in Africa
and around the world at least.
And we speak different dialects
of the Fulani language.
It's called Fulfulde if you are
on the Eastern side of Africa,
starting in Mali and
all the way to Sudan.
But it's called Pular if you
are in Senegal, or Guinea,
or Sierra Leone area.
Fulfulde-- the reason why it's
called Fulfulde in the others
regions-- basically,
Fulfulde means
dialect in the Fulani language.
So basically the
version of the Pular
that's spoken by the other
people is just called dialects,
and then that name stuck.
And the language actually is
referred to now, globally,
as Fulfulde.
Most people know
Fulfulde, and only
a few people except maybe people
from French speaking countries,
refer to the language as Pular.
So as you can see
here, it's part
of the North Atlantic branch
of the Niger-Congo as Wolof
and Serer.
And it's spoken at least
in two dozen countries,
and it's recognized
by the African Union
as one of the official
languages that will eventually
be used in addition to English,
French, Portuguese, Spanish,
and then we'll have Swahili.
And also in the ECWAS, which is
the economic. community of West
African States, has
16 countries that are
members of the organizations.
And Fulani is one of
the languages that
they looking into, because
basically in West Africa,
we have three big
languages that can serve
to unite those countries--
we have the Fulani language,
we have the Hausa language,
and the Mandingo language.
And those are the
transnational languages
in West Africa, spoken
in multiple countries.
And originally the Fulani
language was written--
as you remember, I mentioned
the Fulanis embraced Islam
in the early 11th century--
and then we started using
Arabic, the Arabic script,
to write the Fulani language.
And we used it all over,
but there was no standard.
So each region or each
person or each group
was writing the
Fulani language based
on their own understanding.
Because the problem
is that we have sounds
that are specific to
the Fulani language that
are non-existent in Arabic.
So there was a--
how to create the
correspondence for the letters,
the sounds that
we have, in Arabic
that don't exist in there.
And then the fact
that the Arabs have
some sounds that we don't need.
So people were using some
of those letters in Arabic
as a correspondent
one of the sounds that
existed in our language,
but it's not standardized.
So every person was
doing their own thing.
And I explain the
story of actually how
this whole thing started
that we'll get to later on.
And the reason, in
the '70s, people
started using the Latin
alphabet, but also the problem
with that is, each
country, or each region,
was using their own standard.
In Guinea, actually,
during the first regime,
they used to teach the
national languages in Guinea.
But we were using
an alphabet that
was different from any
of the other countries--
the Latin alphabet.
So for example,
for the sound bah,
we were using bh, while
in other countries
they were using a sign that
looks like a 6, the number six.
So there was a
problem also reading
what's written in Guinea versus
what's written in Senegal
or Mali, for example.
And also one thing that I can
say about the Fulani language--
it's one of the most widely
spoken languages in Guinea.
It's actually the lingua franca
in the central parts of Guinea
all the way to the region--
the lowlands toward the ocean.
And also in Cameroon, northern
Cameroon in the Adamawa region,
it's the lingua franca.
It's one of the most widely
spoken language there.
And the fact that there
were these problems using
different sets of letters
to write the language
is actually what
will lead us to this.
My dad lived in region--
unfortunately, I don't
have a map of Guinea,
but in Guinea we have
four natural regions.
And the Fulani people
mostly live mostly
in the mountain regions.
But my dad moved from
there to go and start
a business in the
forest region, which
was about 800 kilometers away.
And you know, Fulanis
being nomadic people,
so that's how the
spread all over.
Even though they abandoned
cattle herding, some of them
did, but they're still
engaged in other businesses
by traveling to other
regions and other countries.
So the way people
stayed in touch
with their relatives
is by sending letters
to their relatives, and usually
they will write it in Arabic,
using the Arabic letters.
And since there was
no standard, there
were only a few people
who could actually
read a letter for someone.
So my dad was one
of those people who,
if people received letters from
their relatives back in Fouta,
they will send the letters to
him so that he can read them.
So that's how we got into
reading those letters.
We learned it from our dad, and
then we got really good at it.
And then at the end, he
started giving us the letters
to read for the people.
But what we noticed is
that, like I said earlier,
there was no standard.
So most of the time
you were just guessing.
Because you know the language.
If you see something,
the word, you
can actually guess what the
person was trying to write,
even though it's
not exactly how you
think that they would write it.
So that's how I got
to asking my dad,
how come we don't have
our own writing system,
so that we can write in a
way that everyone can read?
Without having to guess,
without having any problems.
And he told us that we
don't have a writing system,
and then that's how I told him
that maybe that's something
that we would looking
into creating.
And my mom also had a
rice bar restaurant--
a small restaurant
next to the market--
where I used to hang
out after school.
And that's where I met
this guy who had traveled
a lot around West Africa.
And he used to tell me a
lot about the Fulani people.
He's the one who first told
me that the Fulanis are prison
all over, because I used
to think Fulanis are only
present in Guinea.
But he said, because we are
present all over Africa,
we speak different dialects
and we write differently.
And then he said that
people-- they've been looking
into unifying the languages,
and then you start reciting name
of people--
well-known peoples in
the Fulani community.
And he told me all
of those people
have looked into creating
an alphabet so that they
can unify the language
that they-- but
have not been able to.
So that combined with what
happened with my dad really
motivated me into looking
into ways to creating
an alphabet for our language.
That's actually how the idea
and the motivation came about.
And then I was always
with my brother.
And then he talked
to me about it.
And then we started the process.
And this is how we started.
Sometime after school, we
would go into our room,
we started drawing
lines, and then
we'll pick whatever looks like
a letter to us from those signs,
as you can see here.
Or the other method
that we could use
is that I would think
of a letter or a sound,
and I would imagine how it would
look like when it's written.
And then I'll draw
based on that.
And that's how we ended up
getting all the letters.
We got 27.
But later it would be
28, because we later
discovered there's one
more sound that we needed.
So we added that later on.
But originally we
had 27 letters.
And then when we created
all those letters,
we told my dad that we
finally created an alphabet,
and he didn't believe us.
So he called one
of his relatives
who used to work
for the government,
and then told that guy to come,
because his sons, his kids have
informed him that they
created an alphabet,
bu the thinks
they're just playing.
So this guy came, and then
he started testing us.
So he would ask me
to leave the room
and then he will tell
my brother to write
a word using the new alphabet.
And then my brother would write
the word, and then I'll come
and then he'll ask me to read
it, and then I would read it,
and it would be
exactly what he asked.
And then he did the same thing.
He asked my brother
to leave the room.
My brother left.
And then he asked me
to write something.
He asked me to write one of
the hardest words that he could
think of in Pular, which
is [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
and then I wrote it, and then
my brother came and read it,
and then he turned to
my dad, and he's like,
I think these guys are
onto something here.
And basically that's how
the writing system started.
The ADLaM.
But back then it
wasn't called ADLaM.
We created the alphabet.
We started working on it.
And then we started teaching--
the first person that we taught
was my sister.
Go on to the next slide.
This is her.
And this is the one of the
first books that we used.
This is actually her
writing back then.
So this is how we
started teaching people.
We didn't have a name for the
alphabet, it was really hard,
and we just kept calling it
Bindi Pular which basically--
literally means the
writing, the Pular writing.
And then we taught her.
And after that we started
going around to the market.
The next slide.
We started teaching
in the community.
And my dad used to own
a shop in the market,
and that's where we
started, because there were
many Fulanis in the market.
So we would go there and teach.
This is me and my brother.
My brother is in
the middle here,
in the yellow and blue jacket.
I'm in the back.
And those are some of the few
people that we taught then.
And two years later,
this is the picture
after we had already
created the alphabet.
And then the next slide
shows how the alphabet looked
in the 1990's.
This is how we used to write it.
And when we created
the alphabet,
because we were heavily
influenced by Arabic,
we started from right to left.
But also since we
are going to school,
we are also influenced
by the French language.
Instead of using diacritical
marks as in Arabic
to mark the vowels, we use
actual vowels in our language.
Because our language is
not the same as Arabic.
Arabic only has three
vowels, but we actually
have five vowels, as in English.
Actually, we used
to think we had six,
but it turns out
we only had five.
So that's why we write
from right to left.
And then we originally
also, all the letters
were joined, as in Arabic.
So this is how we
started writing it.
And these are the
first manuscripts.
And then we started
writing books.
Basically what we
were doing back
then is, the books
that we were studying,
either religious books or
books from our schools,
we would translate them
into our language in Pular,
and write them using
the new alphabet.
And these are books that
we'll then show to people.
And then after the--
because few years
later, sense we
had had a lot of
practice writing,
so then we started
writing this way.
Experimenting writing
the letters separately,
as you can see on
the next slide.
Then I started writing
books with the letters
not joined, actually.
You can't really
tell here, maybe,
because the image
is not that good.
But these actually--
these letters that are not
joined, as you can see.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So we started
experimenting, and then we
noticed that this actually
was easier for people to read.
So we continued on that.
And then I'll let my brother
talk about the next slide.
IBRAHIM BARRY: Like
my brother said,
we have many different phases of
the evolution of ADLaM script.
So the first one we call the
first generation of book.
We call this the first
generation of book, as he said.
It was just the
book and the stories
we used to learn from
my dad and my mom.
We used to write them
and go around the city
and teach people.
And people really liked them.
So by the time we move to the
second generation of book,
we started thinking about the
language, about the structure.
About the laws in the language.
So we continued teaching
people in the market,
around the city, every
time when we come back
from school and
during our break.
We used to teach
people all the time.
So by the second
generation of book,
we have a lot of different book.
But the third generation
of book started in 2000,
when I moved to the University
of Conakry, in my country,
in the capital city.
When I moved there, I
started an organization.
Because all the books from
the first through to second
generation, of them was
writing by my brother.
I used to help him
teaching around the city.
So when I moved
to the University,
I started talking to
some of my friend.
They were really interested
in teaching people.
And so they started
working with us.
From the University we
have five different groups.
We have people going for
medical school, the people going
for engineering school.
We have different
project, so we just
write books that really
affected the life of people.
So when we started
this kind of book,
the script become very poPular.
So like this one--
some of my student
at the University,
who was going for
medical school,
they started writing
books in our language.
How a woman can take care
of her kid, since he--
when he sees that her pregnancy
into her kid is growing up.
The kind of food you
have to give them,
how to take care of them, how
to clean their [INAUDIBLE].
So we started teaching people.
And those book
become very poPular,
and people was
very happy to read.
Because more than 80% does
not know how to read and write
in English language back then--
in French language,
in my country.
We also wrote many
different book--
how to clean water,
because usually people
take water from the well,
so we give them how--
teach them.
Back then I was doing chemical
engineering for my first two
years at the University.
So we learned the process,
and we developed a process
and teach them and show
them how to make those tool.
So around the country--
so after that, we
started a newspaper.
I started a newspaper in Guinea
called [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
or The Pen.
So I used to write all
the news, all the time.
And whenever people
read, they use
sometimes even to
have ears, to cry,
because they know now
how to read and write.
Also we teach people
how to have basic math
to take care of their business.
Because usually a lot of
people put money together.
They will go to
Asia, buy goods, when
they come they have to find
someone who know how to read
and write in French
language to help
them divided this stuff before
they start selling them.
So I teach them how to
do that by themselves.
We give them basic
math, how to divide
[INAUDIBLE] stuff
when they bring them
from Asia or Morocco.
And I started having
problem with the government
because I was teaching
a lot of people.
And also I was one of
the leader of the student
movement at the
university, I was
the president of that movement.
They called [INAUDIBLE]--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Guinean.
So finally I end up going
to prison for three month.
So when I come out,
I continue teaching.
And I used to have a lot
of issues after that.
I went even to Senegal.
I traveled to Senegal,
continue teaching here
at the University
of Senegal with some
of my friend, who taught back
home who move also to Senegal.
They have the same
problem I had in Guinea.
So they was looking
to put them in jail.
So they fled to Senegal.
So I went back to
see them there.
We continued teaching.
When I went to
Senegal, what really
struck I went to the market
with some of these people.
I found the book I was
writing in Guinea already
in the market with ladies.
So I started talking to
some of those ladies.
They told me, can you read this?
I say maybe,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And one of them say,
I can teach you.
I really like this book.
It's really helping me.
And I ask them how
did you got this book?
Because they said, so a
lady is bringing the palm
oil from Guinea, she is the one
who brought those book here.
She is the one who
is teaching us.
But right now, whenever someone
takes something from me,
I write down.
I am following all my
business with this.
And it's really helping me.
And I already started teaching
people classes in the market.
The other ladies.
In 2007 I moved to
the United State.
When I come here,
my biggest goal
was to computerize
the writing system.
Because back in the days, I used
to write everything by hand.
It was very difficult whenever.
You have a mistake
in one page, you're
going to lose all that page.
You have to write again,
before you print the books.
So when I come here
in 2007, I talk
to some of my community members
in New York if they could help.
We're going to have
a software that can
help us write in a computer.
So when I come
back to Portland--
when I come to Portland
to see my brother--
he figure out to find
a company in Seattle
that could done that.
Then we discuss with them.
So we come back, we
didn't have the money.
So we have to work
seven month straight
and save all the money,
100%, and make the software.
We made the software and
we bought some computers.
My brother, in 2007,
went to Guinea.
In 2008, he went to Guinea.
He brought some
of those computers
and teach people how to use
them, how to write book,
and how to edit them.
But this font was on
the Arabic code point.
So we have a lot of
problem using them,
but it makes everything easier.
And we was producing a lot
of books, a lot of newspaper.
And we bought a
lot of computers.
One of the guy in New
York gave many computers.
We send it back home, we started
an organization here called
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
We bought computers, we send for
the teachers, for the writers
back home.
But we still have challenges.
Because we teach a lot of
people, and the internet
is coming back home.
Every villages-- they have
cell phone everywhere,
and people started
calling us all the time.
How can I write this?
How can I text?
I said, we don't have
the solution right now,
but we are doing
some research on it.
That how I started learning
the different process
until we got--
I discover, in order
to be in this system,
to be in Unicode phase.
So this is peoples
teaching back home.
One of these guys, who used
to live in New York, he's--
he just moved back home
in Africa to teach people.
Because he has a Master's degree
in one of the Arab countries,
Syria.
So he will come to New York.
He went to school.
He learned the English
languages, and went back home.
Just, he said, he's moving
back just to teach people
how to read and write.
And they put him
in contact with us.
We taught him how to read
and write the script.
And he found this is the
easiest way to teach people.
The best way is
in their language.
He have taught many different
people around Africa.
So spatially, we focusing a lot
in womans, because most of them
don't go to school.
And children, who parent doesn't
have the mean to go to school.
So we teach them at least
how to read and write.
And then we started newspapers.
We call this newspaper
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Everything going around
the country and Africa.
Is monthly newspaper, it's
still going out every year.
And right now we have some
of very outstanding brothers
who have finished school.
They went for law
school and journalists--
they are the ones who are
running this newspaper back
home.
But before, I am the
one who started it.
I was writing everything.
So now we have people
doing this back home.
So we're still working on
the script and developing it.
And going forward, we have
people writing biology book,
physics, mathematics.
Right now, the basic,
to teach people.
To give them a little
basic in their language
so they can follow what
going on around the world.
But when we made the
software, we have--
I have some issues with
the way the letters was.
So I thought maybe to make
this one very attractive, more
beautiful, I have to take
some calligraphy classes.
So I took those
calligraphy classes with--
in the next slide--
with this lady called Rebecca.
And the first day
of the class, she
used to ask every student, how--
why are you here?
So why are you
taking calligraphy?
So when she asked me, I told her
really why I am in that class.
And I said, I am really
interested in calligraphy
to know some of the
rules and to apply them
into my writing system.
So that how we started working.
She is the one who helped a lot.
She is the one, get me
into different calligraphy
conferences.
And from those
calligraphy conferences,
we get the help to be
encoded in Unicode.
So this is the different--
I even have a font
called after her.
I named one of these font--
this one-- is called
Rebecca, and in our fonts.
We have this way of writing.
So yeah, in the next slide.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: So these
are just different-- once he
took the calligraphy classes,
what you see in these slides
is how the writing
system evolved.
Oh, sorry.
So yeah, so basically
that's all after he
took the calligraphy
classes, he started
making many improvements.
And actually, what was in
the first set of phones
that we created, that was
developed for us in Seattle,
is very different to
what we see today.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, is this
still being written from right?
IBRAHIM BARRY: Yeah--
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Yes--
IBRAHIM BARRY: It's still
right then the left.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: And
then it's also from this,
after he took this
class, then we started
thinking of creating not only--
because originally
we only had one set.
It's right to left,
and it didn't have low
or uppercase very present
in the writing system.
But after he took the
calligraphy classes,
he saw all the
different styles that we
can do with the ADLaM and the
improvement that can be made.
And also the necessity
of having it,
how important it
is for writing--
proper names.
So we-- then he created
another set just
for the uppercase for ADLaM.
So this is just showing
all the different designs
that he's done of the letters.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Yeah.
IBRAHIM BARRY: OK.
So as I told you, in
2014, I was invited
to give a speech, a talk at
the International Calligraphy
Conferences in Colorado Spring.
From that conference, we had
help from some of the peoples
there who help us.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Just
one thing before he
start talking about the thing.
Remember how I told you when
we created the alphabet we
couldn't come up with a name?
So imagine, since the
1990s, all the way til 2012,
we didn't have a name.
We actually experimented, we
thought about different names
on how to call the alphabet.
Whenever people ask us, what's
the name of the alphabet?
We just call Bindi Pular,
which is writing system.
Or, people would call
it the writing system
that came from N'Zerekore,
which is our hometown where
we were born.
But one day,
because the alphabet
became so poPular in
Guinea, so the instructors
they gathered one
day and they say,
we have to give this
alphabet a name.
And they found a
very simple thing.
It's unbelievable.
Because they just took the first
four letters of the alphabet,
and called it.
And we couldn't believe that,
we couldn't even think of that.
As simple as that.
They call it ADLaM--
ah, dah, lah, mah.
And they gave you a
perfect definition,
which is the alphabet
that will prevent
the people from disappearing.
Because that was
one of the things
that most African languages
are confronted with.
You know, there's
French language
in Africa, which is--
actually, in Guinea,
that's the official language.
The language of the instruction.
But in our homes, we
speak our own languages.
In the markets, we
But if you go to school,
you learn French.
And the government--
everything is done in French.
So there is-- our languages
are threatened by the French,
by the French language
or English language.
IBRAHIM BARRY: Or Arabic.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Or
Arabic language, also.
So that's why it made perfect
sense for the alphabet
to be a way to protect our
language from disappearing.
Because if the language is
really the vehicle of culture,
like we say it is--
because if your language dies,
your culture dies with it.
Because there are
certain things that
are specific to cultures that
can only be shared within--
with codes or words
in that culture.
So if you lose
the language, that
means the culture is eventually
[INAUDIBLE] to disappear.
And if the culture disappears,
that means the people.
Not the physical
people, but the people
as in their culture,
civilization,
and their history.
All of that goes with it.
So they came up
with the name ADLaM.
And it was perfect.
It was like, we
couldn't believe it.
And it was perfect
timing because we
were about to start the
process with Unicode.
And it would have been awkward
for us to submit a proposal
and not even have a
name for the alphabet.
So when I moved here, I
started contacting Unicode.
And everything, most of you
know that probably, is--
things move fast or quickly
when you have contacts.
But if you don't have
contacts, usually things
don't move as fast as you hope.
So when I moved in
2004, I actually--
when I started researching
in how to get our alphabet
encoded, I discovered that
there was a Unicode-- a UNESCO
project, a UNESCO-funded
project working
with the University
of Berkeley in trying
to encode some languages.
So I wrote them but
never heard from them.
In 2007 when my brother moved
here, we also wrote to them.
And they replied back.
We started talking a little,
but I didn't get far.
It's now, only when my
brother went to Colorado,
at his second
calligraphy conference--
that's when things
started going forward.
Moving fast.
Because that's where
he met some guy--
at his first conference,
actually, there
was a conference in Portland,
where he met with Randy, right?
And then when he went to the
second conference in Colorado,
Randy introduced him to
somebody called [? Stephan ?]
[? Rapp, ?] I believe.
And this is the guy
who said that he
know somebody working on
the Unicode project that
can help us.
And then he sent an
email, I think, to--
what's her name--
I forgot--
IBRAHIM BARRY: Debbie.
ABDOULAYE BARRY:
Debbie Anderson.
IBRAHIM BARRY: Yes.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: And it turns
out it's the same person that I
had e-mailed previously, but
I didn't get far with her,
but with [? Stephan ?]
[? Rapp's ?] help,
things got really
moving quickly.
And then they put
us in touch with--
so this is Randy, the guy who
introduced us to [? Stephan ?]
[? Rapp, ?] who helped us
get all of this stuff moving.
And then when we talked
to Debbie Anderson, so
he said there's one
person who could
help us write the proposal,
which is Michael Everson.
He's written many proposals
for many African languages,
and he is the one
who did our proposal.
And then he came to Vancouver,
and Washington, which
is very close to
Portland, where we live,
and then we met with him there.
And then we worked on
all the different styles.
And he asked us all the
questions that he needed.
And then he wrote a proposal.
And in 2013-- everything went
really fast after [? Stephan ?]
[? Rapp ?] got involved.
So in November, he already
had a preliminary proposal.
And then he was
invited in New York.
We had a convention-- an
ADLaM convention there,
and then he came to [INAUDIBLE]
with a lot of the people who
are involved in helping ADLaM.
Because this thing, ADLaM,
if it is where it is today,
it is really with the help
of the people in New York.
There are many people there
who understand the importance
of this alphabet.
Some of them did not
go to a French school,
because that's the problem
that we have usually in Guinea.
You If you didn't go to a French
school or an English school,
you are called an
illiterate person.
Even though you are valuable,
you might know certain things.
So these people--
ADLaM has been a way
to bring those
people into the fold.
Or at least to get them
to share what they know
or to contribute in
terms of knowledge.
Because they have knowledge.
They have things that they
want to do for the community.
But without them, they could
not have been able to do it.
And they're the reason
why, actually, ADLaM has
gotten, because with their--
with the few means, they don't
have a lot, by whatever they
have, they invest a lot of
it into ADLaM and trying
to make it move forward.
And the first guy that my
brother showed you here
is General Boubabacar Barry
in this slide, teaching-- he
used to live in New York here.
They are the ones,
actually, who helped send
our guy across West Africa.
That guy-- a few years
ago, he took a tour.
That's how, actually, ADLaM
spread in all these countries.
And people learned about it.
Because he took it all, he went
to Mali, Burkina Faso, Ghana,
Benin, all the way to
Nigeria to teach people.
And wherever he
went, he left a mark.
And eventually that's
what will take off,
and you will see later in
these slides that today,
ADLaM is taught everywhere
across West Africa.
So in May 2014, we received the
first ADLaM chart, the codes.
And we were very excited.
But there were revisions
that needed to be done.
And we were invited
to come down to--
they had a technical
meeting in October of 2014.
So we drove down here.
And then asked us
all the questions.
And then we were told--
[INAUDIBLE] were given the
hope that ADLaM will eventually
be encoded.
We were hoping for the
next year, in 2015,
but it didn't happen,
because everything--
we had everything
hanging onto that.
Like my brother was saying,
people write us, asking us
how can--
when will I be able to text?
When will I be able to go
online and just use ADLaM,
and we know that's not
possible without Unicode.
But once that happen--
so we were hoping it was
going to happen in 2015,
but unfortunately,
it didn't happen.
It happened with Unicode 9.0.
And we were very happy,
and ever since then--
that's where we've met some
of the people we've met.
[? Ruzbeh, ?] is that
his name, I think?
IBRAHIM BARRY:
[? Ruzbeh, ?] yes.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Yeah.
And we established some
contact with him there,
and then they started
working on the font,
the [INAUDIBLE] of font for us.
But after that, in
May, that's when
we got notified that
ADLaM has been approved
for the release in Unicode 9.0.
And so that was a
huge thing for us.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you
guys were very young--
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask, how old
were you when you developed it?
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Between
10 and 11, and my brother
was around 14.
AUDIENCE: OK, so that paves
the way for my next question.
I've been working on a project
for spelling reform for Brazil.
It's a similar situation.
A lot of people
can't read or write,
and the system for
writing down Portuguese--
it doesn't correspond well.
The alphabet isn't
very well suited
to the pronunciation system.
So I really appreciate
what you did as children.
But one of the
difficulties that I
faced in trying to
propose a spelling
reform for Brazilian
Portuguese is
how phonetic versus how phonemic
do you want language to be?
So, obviously I don't
speak your language,
but an example in English
would be the word "better".
So that sound in better, no
word starts with that sound,
it's not really a t, we don't
say beh-ter, it's not a d,
we don't say beh-der,
like in David, beh-der.
It's some intermediate
sound that
only exists between
a stressed syllable
and an unstressed syllable.
That's why we say photo,
but we say photographer,
we don't say "pho-dographer."
So this is like a
really subtle thing
for, I would imagine
someone, who's 11 years old,
to appreciate that.
But you have to teach the
language to other people.
So is this alphabet--
is it very phonetic?
Is it really the way
you pronounce it?
Or is it more abstract,
like you use a symbol
that maybe some people will
pronounce it one way in one
situation, maybe they'll
pronounce it another way
in another context?
Maybe someone in one region will
pronounce the symbol one way.
Maybe someone in another region
will pronounce it another way,
like "bet-ter" in
London Or "bed-ah."
How closely phonetic
is this alphabet?
ABDOULAYE BARRY: It's
very phonetic, actually.
That's actually the
thing that makes it easy.
Because we say the difference
between the alphabet
for the Fulani
language, and English,
and the Latin alphabet for the
English language, is actually,
we write what we say.
It's exactly the
way we pronounce it.
That's how we write it.
There is no sound there
that can be tweaked or--
is very phonetic, basically.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: If it's a
dah, you see it written dah,
it's going to be dah.
Whether it's in
Guinea or whether it's
in RCA-- in the Central
African Republic, CAR.
Or Sudan.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
That reminds me of
a quote by, I think
it was Joseph Priestley,
the discoverer of oxygen
and inventor of
carbonated beverages,
said the only true and just
representation for a languages
is it's spoken form.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Great.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Thank you.
Great question, yeah.
So if you have questions,
you can feel free to stop us.
So the next thing that we will
just talk about, if you go--
keep going--
these are the projects.
After ADLaM has
been encoded, one
of the things that we started
working on with [? Ruzbeh-- ?]
oh, [INAUDIBLE] introduced us.
He connected us,
[INAUDIBLE] font,
trying to get an
[INAUDIBLE] font for ADLaM.
This has been done, finally.
And we're still working on to
make [INAUDIBLE] some changes
to it.
And then what we
really-- we're also
looking into ways to create
additional fonts that really
reflect how--
because the problem
that we have with
the [INAUDIBLE] font
is that since we were not here
to work with those people who
developed or designed
the font for us,
so we could make the changes
as they were creating the font.
So basically, we just
thought-- we gave them
a sheet of paper where
the letters were written,
and then they created
the font from that.
And then we saw
the final product.
But the first font, for
example, we created in Seattle.
We were actually working
directly with these people.
And we were heavily involved.
So we made all the
changes that we needed.
So that's why we're
looking into making font.
And Craig has been helping
us a lot, tremendously.
He's created some really
cool stuff for us, tools
that we are able to use even
to convert from the Arabic--
the font that was based on
the Arabic code points--
to the new ADLaM code points.
And then the other thing
that we were looking into,
because you saw how the Fulani
people are spread from Senegal
all the way to Sudan,
we're looking into creating
a platform-- an
online platform where
people can learn the alphabet.
Because right now,
the way people
learn is actually
through the apps.
WhatsApp.
What's the other one?
IBRAHIM BARRY: Telegram.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Telegram.
And Facebook.
We have many, many
groups on Facebook,
many groups on WhatsApp,
and many groups on Telegram,
where people actually learn.
So we want to actually convert
that into an online platform
where people can actually
learn the alphabet.
Because there are
too many limitations
with WhatsApp or Telegram.
And the other things
that people do usually
is they take a picture and if
they want to send us a message,
they'll write it
with their hands,
and them take a picture of
it, and then send it to us.
Because right now,
we can't really
type in any of the instant
messaging applications.
You can't type using the ADLaM.
And so we want to
create applications
for learning and communication.
And then the other
big project that we
have is the annual convention
that happens in Guinea
now, every year, eventually that
will move to other countries.
So the people-- all of the
people who are involved
in ADLaM-- from all of
the countries in Africa,
and around the world, whether it
is here in America or Europe--
they gather every year in
one place, in one location.
It just happened in December.
So this year, again, it will
happen in December in Guinea.
People will meet
there and then talk
about all the progress
that has been made,
and all the projects that
we're trying to implement,
and all the exchange ideas
and discoveries in ADLaM.
So we are actually
inviting Craig,
if it's possible to attend
to the one that will be held
in Guinea the end of this year.
So the next slides, we just
showed the pictures of ADLaM
being taught in the
different countries,
where they see Guinea--
if you can just keep scrolling--
and then--
IBRAHIM BARRY:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ABDOULAYE BARRY:
So this is Nigeria,
and the country of Niger.
Same.
IBRAHIM BARRY: Nigeria.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: This
is Benin and Togo.
This is in Sierra Leone.
And this is Guinea.
Fouta Djallon is a
region of Guinea.
This is a graduation
all-girls school.
Same.
This is all in Guinea as well.
Cameroon is actually one of the
most dynamic place for ADLaM
right now, and a lot of
involvement new people who've
been working already in the
Fulani language who are getting
now involved with ADLaM.
And they will actually
be attending--
Harvard is organizing
a conference,
because [INAUDIBLE]
been chosen as the book
capital of the world.
And from April
21st to April 23rd,
they will be having
a conference there.
And they've invited
people who are involved
in ADLaM from Cameroon,
Nigeria and Senegal,
who will be attending there
to make presentations as well.
So some of the
challenges that we face.
I mentioned some of them, is how
to get ADLaM into smartphones.
I was saying earlier, we have
at least 250 million users
of smartphones in Africa.
And the thing is, because
Africa started late,
so we are more
into mobile devices
than we are into the
older technology.
So if we really want to get
ADLaM to touch everyone,
because smartphones
are being used even
in the remote villages.
So we need to have ADLaM into
smartphones and computers,
and especially with all the
different platforms that exist,
Android, Windows and iOS.
And one of the challenges
that we have is,
most of the people-- we do
have some people today that
work on ADLaM as full time.
They make it as their
full time activity or job.
But most of-- because
right now, since we
are the ones who started
the ADLaM, the project,
and my brother has done a lot
of research in the language,
so usually when
people write books,
they have to send it to
him to review or edit them.
And that takes a lot of time.
So if you're doing this as
a side job, or as a hobby,
so it's not going
to really work.
That's why we have a
backlog of at least 23 books
so far have not been reviewed
or edited for publication.
And so that's why we have
materials and publication
issues, and that also
comes with funding.
And this is an example
of the messages
that people will send us.
They'll write a message and take
a picture of it and send it.
Because they can actually--
Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: When you review the
books, do you standardize them?
Because you showed
the map of how
dispersed-- you're
a nomadic people,
you're dispersed
all over Africa.
So naturally we would expect
major dialectal differences.
So do you standardize the
spelling to, for instance,
your dialect?
How do you decide how
to standardize it?
ABDOULAYE BARRY:
Well, that's actually
one of the amazing
things about ADLaM.
Because as you said, we
have Fulfulde being spoken
across thousands of miles.
And what ADLaM has helped us
is standardize the language.
Because right now,
originally at the beginning,
when we would talk to
someone who is from Nigeria,
we would have difficulties
communicating with them,
because they speak in
a different dialect.
But now, all the people
who are learning ADLaM,
or who are involved
in the ADLaM program,
we all understand each other.
So usually when we
edit the language,
we are not only
using one dialect,
because the reason why we have
so many different dialects
is also because we are so
mobile, we are nomadic people.
So wherever we go, based on the
environment, and the people who
are there, we will borrow new
words from that community,
and out into the
Fulani language.
But what we are
doing right now is--
the standardization just means
going back to the original.
Because we all speak
the same language.
Structure-wise
it's all the same,
it's just the words that
are usually different.
So we usually-- if, for example,
something is called in Guinea
in a certain way,
and it's called
in a different way
in Nigeria, we just
find the way it's called
in Fulani, originally,
and then we use that.
That's one way we use it.
And then [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
IBRAHIM BARRY: We're also
working-- we already collected
more than 75,000 word.
So we working on the
autography of those word.
And from those
word, I am planning
to produce a dictionary,
a Fulani dictionary.
So as he said,
ADLaM have already
help the language to start to
be standardized, because they
are all using the same books.
And I can say 99
of the book come
through me before they go out.
So I am editing all the
book, so all the people
learning from those book are
learning the same language.
AUDIENCE: So what do you
do if, in one region,
they pronounce the word--
I'm going to make up a word,
I don't know if this is a word
in your language-- one
region they say "poo-lah"
but in another region
they say "poo-rah".
Like with an R. And
then somewhere else they
say it with an L.
Or in one region
they say something with a
B, and in another region
they say it with a V. How do you
decide which region to favor?
IBRAHIM BARRY: Like my
brother said, most of the time
we don't have that kind of
problem, of pronunciation.
Usually we have-- like in
Guinea, some time before,
we didn't know how
we called police.
We only called in French.
But there was another dialect
of the Fulani who has the word.
We actually use that word.
And [INAUDIBLE] people,
this is how we call police.
Before I started
traveling around Africa,
doing research on the
language, we already--
in Guinea we already have lost
the name of the seven days
in our language.
We used to call them in Arabic.
So in my traveling, I saw
one of the group of Fulani
who still have the
seven days of the week,
in the Fulani language.
And I use that one in all the
book, in all the newspaper.
And right now, I can say
most of the Fulani in Guinea
are using that one,
instead of the Arabic one.
That how we are working.
And people really like
the idea using whatever
we have in the language.
Not to borrow that one.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Thank you.
And the other thing that is--
we was-- even though Fulani was
written in Arabic many years,
and everyone was
just writing based
on their own understanding.
So there was no standard.
But what ADLaM is doing
is helping with that.
So if you've written something--
and since the environment also
informs, in many ways, how
people see certain things,
or how words are
added to the language.
For example, there
are certain trees
that exist in Guinea that
don't exist in Cameroon.
But the Cameroonians
know of that
only through reading
French books.
So probably they
call that in French.
But since the trees
in Guinea will just
use the word the name that's
used in Guinea for that tree,
so the Cameroonian
Fulanis don't have
to use the French word anymore.
But that's how we're doing.
So basically what the
language is the same.
But it's just the borrowed
words or the environment
that's creating some
of the differences.
And also there are some changes,
because where the Fulanis are
a very tiny minority, or where
the language has been heavily
influenced by people
who actually learned it,
but who are not originally
Fulanis, like in certain areas
of Cameroon, if the structure
has changed a little bit,
we can actually tell
when we sees it written.
So we just correct the grammar.
Or how-- because people usually
write the way they speak.
And usually the way you speak
is not necessarily the way
you should be.
So those are the corrections
that we usually do.
And people understand them,
because most of the time
it makes sense.
I don't know if
anybody has questions.
So let's see, next slides.
So the other thing that
been happening in Africa
right now is a lot of people
have noticed the limitations
of teaching people in
English, French, or Arabic,
because like I said earlier,
if you go to your house,
you speak in Pular.
You go to the market,
you speak Pular.
But the only time
you hear French
is when you go to school.
Or the only time you
will start learning
French is actually the first
day you sent to school.
That created a
lot of limitation,
and policymakers have
been looking into ways
to bring in our local languages,
at least as a way of teaching
kids in primary school.
There have been some pilot
programs being done either
in Senegal or Cameroon.
And eventually, what that
means with [INAUDIBLE] ECOWAS
and the African Union already
choosing certain languages--
transnational languages--
is that one day,
Fulani will be spoken
not just by the Fulanis,
but by more people in
West Africa, for example.
So right now if there are
50 million speaking Fulani,
eventually there could be 100
or more than 150 million people
speaking.
Because the language
will be adopted.
And the language is the
language of the community.
The people, we know each other.
So it would be easier to teach
somebody in Pular or Fulfulde,
than to teach someone in
English, which is a language
that he's not familiar with.
So maybe, instead of
doing instruction,
learning in French, we
will actually learn French.
But we'll do the learning
in Fulfulde, or Mandingo,
or Hausa, for example.
So also, the other thing
that's the great with ADLaM
is that since ADLaM is
spreading a lot in Nigeroa,
we have a huge Fulani community.
The Hausas are also--
some Hausas are
looking into adopting
the ADLaM alphabet to write
their own language also.
And the director of the African
Languages program at Harvard
has also expressed
interest in using
ADLaM to write the
Swahili language,
because he learned that
Swahili and Fulfulde are
both non-tonal languages.
Because he's already looking
into another script that's
used in Africa for Kikuyu,
which is a tonal language.
But Fulani is not
a tonal language,
so he thinks that ADLaM will
be more appropriate for that.
So he'll looking into that.
And he'll be at the
conference in Conakry.
So there's also
a huge presence--
if you go on Facebook,
you look up Fulani groups,
you will see hundreds of them.
We are very active
on social media.
And many groups are promoting
not only ADLaM but all
the aspects of the
Fulani culture.
And there are many
movements supporting
the ADLaM, especially
in Nigeria, in Guinea,
and Cameroon.
And so if you go
on social media--
because Nigeria is the biggest
country in Africa, it's like,
more than 180 million people--
and if you get a list,
even 10% of those,
to get involved in something,
you create a huge impact.
And that's what's
happened with ADLaM,
because since
Nigeria got involved,
it's gotten really big.
Whether it's online
or on the ground.
And so they've opened--
the way things are so big
there is that sometimes when
they doing a graduation ADLaM,
they actually do at stadiums.
Which is very different
from Guinea, because Guinea
is a small country of
only 12 million people,
compared to Nigeria, so.
So this is where we stand today.
I don't know if there's
anything else left.
So yeah, these are
pictures of graduations.
But we have so many
pictures, but we
didn't want to turn the
presentation into just
a slideshow of pictures.
But if you go on Facebook,
you do a hashtag #adlam,
you might see a lot of
stuff, or if you go online.
We are actually
creating websites
where we will collect
all of this stuff
and put it there, for people to
know what's going on on ADLaM
today.
So thank you all for listening,
and thank you for coming.
And if you guys have any
questions, we'll feel free.
We actually wanted to do only
30 minutes presentation and 30
minute questions, but so
many things we talk about.
But yeah, thank you so much.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: So you'll be
happy to take questions?
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And my question was
about sorting your alphabet.
So when you made your alphabet,
how did you decide how you
so-- like in Arabic, you
have [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
but you went with
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ABDOULAYE BARRY:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH], yes.
AUDIENCE: How did
you decide that?
ABDOULAYE BARRY: I
think the most obvious--
it was the way we came
up with the letters.
So sometimes we would
just make signs,
and then when we'd pick a
letter from those signs,
we will call the--
we'll decide to
call [INAUDIBLE]--
give it a name.
And that's how we actually
organized the alphabet.
Or if I think of a letter--
for example, I had a friend.
When I would go to class, I
would start writing things
to share with him.
And then if I start writing
something and I'm blocked,
stopped somewhere, because
I don't have that letter,
so that day if I go home, that's
the letter I'll be creating.
So then I'll add it to the list.
And that's how we
completed the list.
And we never really--
after we completed
the set, the 27,
we really never went back
and changed the order.
So basically we made the list
as we created the letters.
But we already knew we wanted
to-- the [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
wanted to be the first
letter we created, of course,
because it was the first
letter of my name anyway,
so I wanted it to
be the first letter.
And it's the first letter in
every other alphabet, almost.
AUDIENCE: I have kind
of a related question.
I was kind of struck by
how much attention there
was to the aesthetics of it.
Like, you started out with
this sort of automatic writing
and visualization, and
then you talked about some
of these decisions,
like, do we join letters?
Or do we split them up?
And then you go into
these calligraphy classes
to really kind of polish it.
So I guess I'd just
like to know what--
anything you want to say about
that attention-- real attention
to appearance?
What your overall
strategy is, how
you think that maybe
has been beneficial
for adoption and
reception of the language?
I mean, clearly ADLaM is
successful, and as you've said,
there have been other
efforts to do this.
So I'm wondering if the
aesthetic attention there
is part of that.
ABDOULAYE BARRY: Yes,
it has always been.
When we first created
the alphabet, the more we
wrote books, the
more we realized
we can refine the letters.
And that's how you
saw the evolution
from how we were writing all
of them joined and then we
went to unjoined letters.
And also what do we notices
is, the better the letters look
to people, the more interested
they are to the alphabet.
Because the colonization
has had a huge impact on us,
and sometimes it's
hard for us to look
into things that come from our
own culture as very valuable.
Because basically, for
colonization to succeed,
you have to basically
make people think
that they're not that valuable.
They have to take
everything from you--
the language, the culture.
So that mentality still
exists in our community.
So aesthetics a
lot of part of it.
And like my brother said, when
we created the first keyboard,
and then we started
typing with it,
he realized that it didn't
look as good as he wanted.
And that's how he got
interested into calligraphy.
And he's been making
amazing stuff with it.
And it looks--
some of it looks--
way, if you took what
we wrote in 1990,
you compare it to
what's coming out today,
from some of the stuff
that he's developing,
it looks very different.
And it looks way better.
And yeah, aesthetics is--
especially in our culture, if
you go on YouTube, actually.
Go look up the Wodaabe, you'll
see how Wodaabe people--
W-O-D-A-A-B-E-- look
that up on YouTube,
and you'll see how beauty is
important in Fulani culture.
And so--
AUDIENCE: I was wondering what
you do about other symbols,
like punctuation?
Do you have commas,
dashes, parentheses, stuff
like that in your system?
Or do you have regular
Latin or Arabic punctuation?
ABDOULAYE BARRY: So
since the writing
goes from right to
left, we use many
of the Arabic punctuations.
And we do have some
different ones,
because the Fulani language is--
so my brother is actually the
one who came up with that--
when we are talking,
sometimes you'll
say an affirmative sentence.
If it's written--
it's not a question.
But it's only a question
by how it sounds.
So that's how we came up
with different symbols
to indicate whether a
sentence is actually
a question before
you start reading it,
so you know how to
change your tone.
AUDIENCE: OK, so that's also
part of your writing system,
is some of this
additional punctuation.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
how you typically represent
numbers in the script?
Do you use the Latin digits,
ASCII digits one, two, three,
do you use Arabic, or do
you have your own digits?
And do you usually use a
base 10 numbering system?
Or do you use something else?
ABDOULAYE BARRY: So we
have our own set of digits,
the 10 digits from 1 to 0.
We don't use the
Latin or the Arabic,
because basically
the problem also
is, since the writing system
goes from right to left,
and the way we read numbers
is also from right to left.
So we created, also, digits
to represent numbers that also
go from right to left as well.
So if we're writing 1996,
for example, it would go--
if somebody is reading--
it would be like 6991,
if it's in Latin or Arabic.
So we have our
own set of digits.
And also the thing with
ADLaM is that since people
view it as original-- when
we first created this,
it was just a way
for us to maybe solve
a problem of standardization.
By now, it has become something
bigger, as a way actually
to educate more people.
Because like my brother say,
we have a huge percentage
of people that don't
go to school in Guinea.
Or everywhere in Africa.
But that's because education
is not done in our languages,
it's done in foreign languages.
So basically if
you don't know how
to speak French, or
English, or Arabic,
you are considered
an illiterate person.
So a newspaper-- you will
not have access to it.
Or information
given on the radio--
you will not have
access to that as well.
And one of the most
amazing things that--
or the most fulfilling
thing for me
is, when my mom came here to
visit a few years ago, in 2012,
and this area is very
different from Africa.
In Africa we live in
communities where everybody
is outside, but here what
was very different for her
is the fact that
everyone lives inside.
When you go in your
house, you lock your door.
And you don't-- you know.
So it was very hard for her.
So if we go to work, she would
spend all her day at home,
not have anything to do.
So the only way for
her-- she's never
been to a French school
or English school.
So she doesn't know how to read
or write in English or French.
So the only way she can
pass her time all day
was reading the
ADLaM newspapers.
And one day she said--
IBRAHIM BARRY: And books.
ABDOULAYE BARRY:
Yeah, and books.
And she said she did not
realize how lost she was.
Because now she can
read the newspaper
and know what's going
on around the world.
And that was really amazing
for me, it had a huge impact.
Like, even if it was
just left to this,
if this was where it
was actually with ADLaM,
I'm satisfied.
AUDIENCE: One of my models
for success in a language
is that people are able to
use it for everyday things.
And texting is one
of those things.
If ADLaM were available
on mobile devices,
would young people be
texting their friends,
lying to their parents
about where they're going
after school, things like that?
ABDOULAYE BARRY:
Yes, absolutely.
Because like I said, people want
to use so bad, sp even to text,
they'll just write it
on a piece of paper
and take a picture
of that and send it.
Just because they
want to text in ADLaM.
And like I-- also
we said, most people
don't go to French
or English school.
So it's easier for them to just
text in their own language.
And if ADLaM is
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And it's also, people feel
more comfortable writing
in Fulfulde using ADLaM
than actually writing
it using another alphabet.
Because if somebody texts
you or writes something,
make a comment on Facebook,
in Pular or Fulfulde using
the Latin script, it's an
exercise to actually figure out
what's written there.
Because nobody goes to school.
Most people don't go
to school and learn
how to write in Pular
using the Latin alphabet.
And since, as that question
about phonetic sense,
ADLaM is very phonetic.
So the way you read it is
the way-- or the way you say
is the way you write.
So the chance of
mistakes is very slim.
IBRAHIM BARRY: And like
I said at the beginning,
smartphone are everywhere,
but the only thing people
do with their smartphone is
just calling and receiving.
And now they know they can read
and write in their language,
but they cannot do
the other functions.
They cannot write
the name and save.
The most of the time--
most of the people I meet
who didn't go to school,
they just memorize numbers of
the people they really know.
They don't save names.
Or they have is
notebook they write.
But if ADLaM is in their system,
they can write their name.
Save their schedules.
It's going to be amazing.
ABDOULAYE BARRY:
And the other thing
is also the economics of it.
Because it's cheaper
to text than to call.
So people prefer to
send text messages.
And like I said, we
are nomadic people.
And even though we don't
follow cattles everywhere now,
but it's basically in our blood.
Fulani people travel light.
It's very rare to see
a Fulani person who's
living in the region
where he was born.
And for that reason, people
are always communicating.
Figuring out ways to
communicate with each other.
And texting is one of the most
amazing ways people can text.
So there are Fulanis
everywhere in the world.
So you can go to a
city, big city where
you will not find a Fulani.
And there's actually a saying
in our culture, or in Africa--
if you go to a place and you
see no Fulani there, move.
Because that place is not good.
IBRAHIM BARRY: The other tribes
say that, like the Mandingo.
ABDOULAYE BARRY:
So we travel a lot.
And we need to communi-- we
need to stay in con-- because we
were the only few
people also that
use-- it was part of our
culture to write letters
and go to the market
or to your park
and give it to some
random person and say,
I have one of my relatives that
live in the city called Lola,
and I don't know
exactly where he lives.
So I give him the letter and
then the person would take it
and then go looking for certain
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] from
[INAUDIBLE] until they find
him and give him the letter.
And then he will take the letter
to somebody who will read it.
So yeah, communication.
Texting.
If we were able to text, that
would makes a huge difference
for ADLaM and for the people.
SPEAKER: I would love
to thank our speakers,
and our honored guests
from around the world.
And all of the Google people.
And all of the people who will
be seeing this later on Talks
At Google.
[APPLAUSE]